[Music]
welcome to the vr drop zone live in the
bleacher report app the nfl schedule has
dropped and it is futures week here on
vr betting my name is connor rogers and
for the first time since the super bowl
we are reunited the man of the people
he's got a lot of good stuff today to
give away and a lot of good locks as
well greg ivory greg how we feeling man
what's going on
connor it's been that long it does not
seem like it's been that long but uh do
a good man can't complain just ready to
give out some winners and looking for
some winners from the fans in the
comments
that's the goal here the nfl season
kicks off september 8th but there are
there is plenty of action to be had
right now and we've teamed up with
draftkings as we do here to give you an
in-depth look at our favorite nfl
futures bets we're going to talk our
best bets from everything win totals
super bowl mvp odds but that is not all
greg let the people know what you're
giving away today
connor we are giving out an abundance
we're giving out hoodies we're giving
out five jerseys over a thousand dollars
in dk
cash money uh and our grand prize connor
our grand prize we're giving
a bankroll to a fan we're giving one
lucky winner 250 dollars a month
for all
of the football season so get in those
comments
drop your winners only please
[ __ ] hook y'all up with some prizes
man actually connor i'm feeling so
generous
i'm in the comments right now looking
for some locks
looking for some takes
i got gabriel dania says
stop trolling this is winners only the
fans are looking for winners only connor
therefore gabriel you are walking away
with the hoodie of your choice because
this is not a trolling matter we are
here looking for locks we're looking for
winners we are trying to win some money
this football season and i got uh we we
is in the comments they are rocking with
the bears under so guess what we
go get you a bears jersey because i'm
giving you a jersey of your choice
connor
i think it's time let's get this thing
going brother
it's time the futures are now let's dive
in and what better to start with than
win totals for the eight most popular
teams as you see the board right here
green bay big expectations set at 11.
dallas set at 10 and a half and maybe a
weak division tampa bay and the bills
are the highest on this board at 11 and
a half no surprise there with tom brady
and josh allen the chiefs at 10 and a
half feels a little disrespectful to the
chiefs san francisco your niners greg at
10 and then the eagles and vegas two
teams on the rise right now set at eight
and a half and you see how popular that
eagles bet has been it's already at
minus 150 so a lot of people on the over
for the philadelphia eagles to get to
that nine mark greg what do you like
here and what do you need from our
lovely audience right now to get this
going
connor what i need everybody to do is
get in the comments and tell us your
best bet for win totals you can tell me
an emojis you can tell me in words you
can tell me and gives you could tell me
however you want but most importantly
connor we on this show we are looking
and we need winners only please i'm
giving away a jersey and a hoodie to my
favorite comment
tur so connor
i'll give my take here
you know and the fans know i'm from the
bay area i am a niner fan and the las
vegas raiders was formerly the oakland
raiders they were right across the bay
from the san francisco 49ers and there
is a big rivalry with all that being
said with the rivalry intact with my
my outlook on the raiders i am going to
bet on the raiders because i like money
i'm gonna take the raiders win total
over they're gonna go over eight and a
half they had a tremendous offseason got
a new gm got a new coach added devonte
adams also added chandler jones i can
see them taking one game away from the
chiefs one game away from the chargers
and one game away from the broncos
and that'll leave them in that area to
go over this win total connor talk to me
though talk to the people which team are
you riding with
greg i like the division that you're
looking at i'm sticking with it as well
in the afc west yes the easy one here to
me is the the eagles but they're set at
-150 for a reason so we're gonna make
this a little bit more difficult i'm
looking at the chiefs in that afc west i
think you're on it greg a lot of wins
are going to come out of this division
across the board for all four teams i
like that the raiders are set a little
lower i still think 10 and a half is low
for the chiefs you're telling me all
they have to do is get to 11. they're
the team that usually comes out on top
in those close division games they've
been there before and i think they're
ready to go i know tyreek kills out but
they got a lot of mouths to feed that
they could spread the ball around with
patrick mahomes i love what they did in
the nfl draft so the chiefs over 10 and
a half is what i'm on right now greg
what's the audience saying are they
rolling with us are they looking in the
different direction here
uh let me see i'm in the comments right
now i got dre m series says dallas over
it's a lock 11 plus wins in the nfc east
is easy uh i got oh you're gonna like
this one conor
david
barakat david barakat says jets over
connor you were a jetspin he is riding
with your jets i'm saying that they are
going over
one more one more for you connor zack
young says chargers are going to take
the afc west wow so i'm assuming that
they're going to go over the win total
if they're going to win that division
you said there's going to be a lot of
wins i think there's going to be a lot
of wins so we'll see if this charter
team has what it takes but i do want to
mention all three of you guys are
walking away with hoodie but connor the
producer just whispered into my ear and
said give away a jersey greg so i'm back
into the comments and i'm looking for
somebody to give away a jersey to and i
see
viviano m viviano m he spelled it out
for us connor e a e-a-g-l-e-s
eagles eagles eagles
okay i mean i i i like the take i like
to take the eagles have been uh talked
about a lot in this offseason with a new
edition of their wide receiver aj brown
but
shout out to you you are walking away
with a jersey
shout out to you man i want a jersey
i like it greg a lot of good vibes so
far and i like the eagles pick so a good
giveaway there all right you've been
betting all week on your favorite win
totals bets we posted on social dk is
letting you that's right they are
letting you boost the odds the team with
the most action uh is getting in odds
boosts and we're gonna announce it here
right now so you see the win total over
unders there from vr betting
and man
this is exciting because this is gonna
move the line significantly for whoever
the most popular one is greg
tell the people which team which over
underpick has the most votes right now
all right here we go here we go here we
go and the winner is
connor
your
new york jets brother
wow the new york jets coming in as the
uh uh the win total boost right here the
jets odds to have over five and a half
wins are being boosted from minus 140 to
plus 110 get on draftkings to take
advantage of this boost it's only
available until sunday at midnight
eastern time so the jets a really low
total there they got to get to six wins
greg they play 17 games now the jets
don't get the six wins i don't know what
to tell my new york jets anymore so love
the boost a big shout out to draftkings
right there all right let's take a
little early look at the best regular
season bets here the schedule has
dropped all odds for all games
throughout the entire 2022 season except
cleveland are available now and
obviously cleveland maybe some pending
news at quarterback there that's why
those odds aren't up all odds are
available now in draftkings greg
what matchup you already got your eyes
on i know you don't waste any time you
don't take the summer off you don't sit
aside you got your eyes on something
early what are you looking at here
connor i was looking at the match-ups
earlier
and i saw the buffalo bills i saw them
week one buffalo bills was taking on
the la rams
and the buffalo bills are minus one it's
an even match up
i think and i strongly believe connor in
the super bowl hangover and i think week
one
i think that happens in l.a and they're
going to be happy about winning the
super bowl the game is in la and i think
the buffalo bills are going to go out
there and take care of some business
get it now it's almost even money the
line might jump so go get it now connor
talk to me and talk to the people
which line were you looking at
nobody loves a good super bowl hangover
more than greg and i like that theory
there and greg i'm gonna take a page out
of your playbook because of that i'm
looking at your niners week one they are
a six and a half point favorite against
the bears and i'm sorry bears fans it's
just tough to believe in you right now
after that off season where there was
really no action to make this team much
better
i don't care who's playing quarterback
for the niners whether it's jimmy g
whether it's trey lance i'm just a
believer in kyle shanahan
over the bears i'm a believer in that
niners defense over the bears that have
some holes at wide receiver they have
some holes at offensive lines so the
bear is six and a half that's the line
uh the
niners six and a half over the bears
week one is the line that i'm all over
make sure to visit draftkings to bet
your favorite regular season games but
let's keep the show moving we have more
uh to give away including our grand
prize a 250
per month bankroll during the entire
football season so let's move on and
take a look at some division winners
we're going to look at one of the most
hotly contested divisions the afc west
greg and i already dived into that we
like that he likes the raiders i like
the chiefs we like wins we like wins to
come out of this division so let's take
a look at the odds board uh to run away
with the most competitive division of
football the chiefs at plus 165 the
chargers one of the teams on the rise in
the off season power rankings at plus
230. the broncos led now by russell
wilson plus 275 and then maybe a little
disrespect here for a highly competitive
raiders team from last year that now has
devonte adams at plus 600. greg what do
you like here and what do you need from
the audience right now
what i need everybody in the comments to
do
is get in the comments and tell us your
best bet to win the afc west i'm giving
away hoodies and i'm also giving away a
jersey connor i'm going to keep this one
simple
sweet and straight to the point no tyree
kill but the chiefs bought in some
reinforcements juju smith schuster
marquez valdez scantling and ronald
jones i'm rocking with the chiefs i do
think the raiders are gonna go over the
win total connor
plus money on the chiefs to win their
division give it to me any
day of the week i'm taking the chiefs
which way are you leaning brother
i'm riding with you greg i feel like
those are those are trap odds people
look at and go man only plus you know
plus 165 i think that's great it's the
chiefs they've been one of the best
teams in football for a long time now
under patrick mahomes and andy reid i
love what they did this offseason the
tyree kill trade doesn't scare me in any
way like you said uh they spread around
the targets now they also drafted sky
more so they got a deep threat there
they drafted really really well this
offense is going to be firing i have a
belief in the chiefs that they remain
the kings at the top of that division
despite how good the charges are going
to look this year the raiders and the
broncos as well the audience riding with
us though right now are they uh they
doubting the chief's reign here
connor let me hop into these comments
and see which way they are riding k-rob
24 is riding with us he says chiefs are
gonna roll easy money shout out to uk
rob we're switching it up i'm sending
you a jersey k-rob so get that jersey
rock that thing well man tag me on
instagram my repo it don't matter where
rock that jersey because you were
walking away with one let's move on i
got eric solis six says wilson is taking
that division shout out to you eric
you're walking away with a hoodie uh
one more one more connor
eric's also saying the broncos is going
over 10. so i'll just give eric another
hoodie why not uh shout out to everybody
that i mentioned you all are walking
away with hoodies or a jersey
all right visit draftkings for the
remaining division odds and while you do
that we had a chance to talk futures
with the host of the gojo podcast from
draftkings mike golick jr take a look
all right we're here talking nfl futures
with mike golick jr host of the go joe
podcast from draftkings mike what's
going on man thanks for joining us not
too much it's exciting we got football
to talk about the springtime what's
better than that it really doesn't get
better than that especially with these
crazy early features so last year the
bengals were 100 to 1
to win the super bowl and they nearly
pulled it off you had a ticket on that
you must have been holding your breath
like no other i know this is a crazy
question so it's not what team is
definitely going to be this year's
bengals but if anybody has that kind of
shot to make that kind of jump who is
yeah you know what you look for what
went into the bengals season right you
had a young quarterback in his second
year coming off of what had been a
lackluster year one largely because of
injury and then got an influx of
offensive talent in that season
i would say looking in that range the
bears are interesting to me in that
regard justin fields was a game changer
in college obviously dealt with an
offense that didn't maximize his skill
set last year he gets luke gets he is
his offensive coordinator coming from
working in that green bay offense you've
got byron pringle eq st brown and we've
heard all about bayless jones their
rookie draft pick and the relationship
he's already building with fields so if
you take that combined with some of the
sack potential on the other side on
defense they could be an interesting one
in that long shot range all right if we
gave you a thousand dollars and you had
to put it on one of two win totals to go
over look at the jets we'll look at both
new york teams so look at the jets they
are at five and a half right now that
line has not moved since the draft or
the giants who are at a little bit of a
beefier seven who would you take
oh god you guys are really sick for this
one yeah i know but we are
but uh i'll say i probably air with the
giants on this one now brian dabo dabo's
certainly exciting we saw what he did
maximizing the skill set of one
quarterback that people had questions
about early on and so maybe that's a
helpful antidote for daniel jones who
hasn't quite put it together yet but i
also look at what we know about the
schedule coming out here so the nfc east
is going to draw the nfc north and the
afc south on this one so the nfc north
and a bit of flux and we know the afc
south outside of the now tom brady full
buccaneers
there's some winds to be had in there
the af the nfc east excuse me as a
division i think is a lot more up for
grabs than what the jets are dealing
with in the afc east where you've got
the super bowl champion favorites in
your division you've got the patriots
that are always the thorn in your side
miami made major moves this offseason
and they're gonna draw the nfc north and
the afc north which is a super tough one
so jets roster still a little bit away
even though i think there's a lot of
players to be excited about about that
team all right give us a non-quarterback
that we should be considering placing an
mvp vet on right now derek no surprise
derek henry has the best odds at 50-1
traditionally a quarterback roll but is
there anybody you like outside of the
quarterbacks yeah i think i'd go back to
the jonathan taylor well and we know he
got a lot of that mvp buzz during last
year running back for the colts but i
think bringing matt ryan over this is
going to be a more stable offense they
drafted alec pierce as one of their top
picks the wide receiver out of
cincinnati so another big body guy for
that receiving core a defense that i
think really up front you know for them
a defense last year what they were able
to do i know they're losing matt
eberflues but i think there's going to
be so much stability and a better
offense around him that that could open
up more opportunities for jonathan
taylor and
i think they'll be making some serious
playoff buzz which we know that sell is
a big part of a player outside of the
quarterback ranks having the potential
to crack an award like this so we've
seen a crazy influx of talent in the afc
this offseason with all of the trades
that have impacted that conference and
it leaves the nfc uh a little bit more
wide open compared to the afc is there a
team that you think people are sleeping
on in the nfc that could ultimately
steal the conference yeah you know we
talked about this division already i'll
say the philadelphia eagles we know they
were a lot of the draft noise there the
aj brown trade bringing him over from
tennessee they got two of my favorite
players in the draft both out of georgia
indeed tackle jordan davis and then his
teammate nicoby dean who felt like the
steal of the draft at linebacker for so
many people i don't think jalen hurts is
necessarily the long-term answer there
still i think he ends up being a
high-end backup but
he understands how to work in this
offense now him and nick siriani worked
out a lot of the kinks last year and if
that offensive line is healthy if you've
still got miles sanders there in the
backfield you've got an offense that
developed a pretty clear identity and if
that defense can do a better job of
getting to the quarterback
i think there's at least potential there
in a conference that's certainly the
weaker of the two i like it teams that
can run the ball always got a shot once
they get in and the eagles they know how
to run the football all right mike
before we let you go where can the
people check out your podcast for
draftkings yeah gojo uh it is five days
a week monday through friday available
on apple podcast spotify google podcast
wherever you hear things we are going to
meet you there and we look forward to
talking with you all right great stuff
from mike golic jr thanks so much for
the time thanks for having me really
appreciate it
my man mike golick jr and connor looking
good there connor rogers talking nfl
futures but i want to talk hoodies and i
want to talk 250
in dk dollars because that's what i want
to give away right now connor i am in
the comments looking for takes
uh people are asking how do they get
their hoodies how are they going to get
their jerseys how they're going to get
their dk dollars do not worry we will
hit you up on messenger on the app so
check your messages on the app you will
see something from vr betting or
bleacher report we will hit you uh i'm
in the comments though
i got
three four five four says jets long shot
is more likely to me shout out to you
jojo you are walking away with a hoodie
um
i see i also see ajuan ajuwon says
detroit lions are the king of the north
i think he means that they're going to
win
the nfc north wow that is a huge huge
take conor i mean i'll give it to him i
like i like the confidence i like i
don't know if i like the take but i like
the confidence so just because of the
confidence you are walking away with 250
dk dollars i have one more hoodie to
give away connor one more hoodie to give
away
and it's going
to jplev 221
oh sorry about that 2-2-1-0 and guess
what connor he's showing love to your
new york jets he says the jets are going
to go over they're going to go easy over
they're going to get seven wins
so therefore
i'm giving him a hoodie just for you
connor that's just for you brother
i appreciate you greg and he should uh
he should get in on that odds boost and
get it at plus 110 on draftkings instead
of minus 140. all right we have a lot
more to give away including a 250 a
month bankroll for the football season
so let's keep it moving and talk odds to
win the conferences right here all right
here are the odds to win the nfc
championship no surprise there tom
brady's bucks at the top super bowl
champs not the favorites right here
they've lost some big time names like
von miller andrew whitworth retired
packers of aaron rodgers always going to
be in the mix there plus 500 greg's
niners at plus 750 then it gets a little
wonky here you got dallas you got
arizona as long shots philadelphia has
longer shots and then the vikings at
plus 2200 all right all right so greg is
there anything you like here and what do
we need from the audience right now to
get involved in the little conference
championship futures action
first and foremost i need to everybody
to get in the comments and tell us who
you think is winning the nfc i'm giving
away hoodies and a jersey connor i'm
gonna get right to it you guys are
probably gonna be like greg you're a
niner fan greg why are you picking the
no i do not want to hear it this team
was in the nfc championship last year
with jimmy garoppolo as their
quarterback yes jimmy garoppolo was the
quarterback and this team got to the nfc
championship i think that they're going
to take a step up in quarterback by
putting trey lance out there
with the same team almost the same team
is coming back for the 49ers i don't
really know too many uh losses that the
49ers took that that are eye-opening as
far as in free agency but this pretty
much is the same team coming back with
the better quarterback connor i can see
them taking the nfc
this year i mean look at the odds
they're plus seven i like those odds
over green bay over the books over the
rams we all know about super bowl
hangovers but i'm rocking with the
niners plus 750 give me the niners
we're improving on quarterback and we
have kyle shanahan as the coach you
mentioned earlier what kyle shanahan
does to an offense i mean we're gonna
see what he's gonna do to an offense
with an actual quarterback that can
throw the ball
connor which way are you leaning
it's all about trey lance if for those
niners greg it's all about trey lance
see if he could be an upgrade over jimmy
g
i'm gonna glean a little chalk here i'm
gonna go with the bucks and i just i
have a rule that i don't really pick
against tom brady uh especially in these
scenarios where he couldn't go out a
loser he came back from one this feels
like one last big run before he gets all
that tv money from fox so plus 3 30. i
still think those odds are fine it's not
crazy value you're not throwing the
house on this but you throw a little bit
on it at plus 3 30. brady it feels like
all the pieces are there they got chris
godwin back healthy they got mike evans
gronk is gonna come back after otas he
just doesn't feel like dealing with ots
and i'd rather enjoy his spring so
i'm gonna lean with the bucks i know
it's a chalky pick but i think brady's
got one more super bowl running him i
don't know if he's got a super bowl
title greg but he's got some one more
super bowl run so i know the comments
are jumping and i know you have an nfl
jersey to give away to them
i am in the comments i'm in the comments
and they are all over me picking the
niners
i also see some fly eagles five shout
out to you d dukes 21 you are walking
away with the hoodie i'm also giving
away a uh
a jersey here i see uh
i see rb139 says tampa they still got
brady don't adam shout out to you rb139
you were walking away with a hoodie uh
quincy
quincy says
why change jimmy dude wins
he wins
but you can always
improve if there's an upgrade out there
why not improve also
it's been it's been reports i i think
the niners might be trading jimmy
garoppolo who knows we'll see how that
plans out uh but
you you you always want to improve in
this league you always want to get
better and i feel like the niners can
get better with trey lands at
quarterback uh shout out to you though
you are walking away with the jersey
that i'm giving out in this segment
connor
i think it's time to talk some afc
championship now though brother
yeah this is where it gets a little more
dicey right this is where all of the big
moves were made this offseason we saw
russell wilson come over from the nfc to
the afc we saw matt ryan do the same
this afc is going to be a bloodbath and
let's take a look at the odds and the
odds are going to show you that obvious
the bills at the top big time favorites
plus 330 they're looking for revenge
against those chiefs that are the
runner-ups here at plus 550. you got the
chargers a huge rise at plus 800 they
didn't make the playoffs last year in
their plus 800. the broncos after
acquiring rust plus 850. the bengals who
were in the super bowl last year who won
the afc last year disrespected at plus
1100 the colts like i said matt ryan
there now plus 1200 baltimore's made a
ton of great moves especially in the
draft and then tennessee all the way
down the board they were the afc's
number one seed last year but they've
lost a lot of big time pieces that have
them down the board at plus 1500 so
greg you uh you took a little bit of a
a risk with your nfc pick you didn't
start at the top of the odds board what
do you like with the afc that seems to
be
much much tighter
connor in the afc i am eating chalk give
me the chalk cause i will eat it
buffalo bills i like them to win the afc
this year they have a bad taste in their
mouth what happened in the playoffs last
year i think they're going to come back
with the vengeance they also added some
reinforcements connor some good
reinforcements my man von miller oj
howard to help out that offense and
jamison crotter in the slot that can
help free up uh my man stefan diggs for
josh allen so uh i like what the buffalo
bills did in the offseason they have
that bad taste in their mouth and i
think that they're gonna come this
season with the vengeance and uh
i can see them going to the super bowl
connor talk to me talk to the people
which way are you leaning as far as in
the afc
well i gotta say greg you've been on the
bills before they were the chalk pick at
the top so nobody can hate on you for
riding with them again here nobody can
hate on you for that i'm gonna roll with
the chiefs right now i i look at this
and just go man i think everybody is
overreacting to them losing tyreek hill
there's no doubt there's not a player in
the nfl like him with his kind of speed
but
i think patrick mahomes is not that he's
ever had the training wheels on but he's
ready to know what it's like without
that number one wide out and he'll
spread the ball around you still have
travis kelsey there i think this team
with their offensive line is going to be
able to run the ball and i think the
defense is going to be a lot better with
the draft picks and the signings that
they've made whether it's justin reed
once again they drafted a lot of defense
got trent mcduffie george carloftus
they've done a lot of really nice things
to diversify and round out this roster
than rather it being a little bit top
heavy for once so i like the chiefs to
come out of the afc but i do think it's
going to be close i i hope this is the
match up right here i hope we get bills
chiefs again
this time obviously in the afc
championship with a little bit of a rule
change where are the comments going
right now i think this is going to be
one of the
the most up in the air ones i think
everybody's going to have a different
opinion i will say i like the colts as a
dark horse pick here if i had to get one
way off the board i would take the colts
as the dark horse big
connor i'm in the comments right now but
before i get into the comments i do want
to say if we get that match up again
chiefs bails connor you know what we're
doing hammering the over but i'm in this
come in the comments i'm in the comments
i see breed winners winner says bills
are stacked vonn abouts the push for
defensive player of the year denver will
make a splash though okay shout out to
you breed winners you are walking away
actually breed winners i love that take
so i'm giving you a jersey now giving
away some hoodies aiden malloy 34 says
bronco is going to surprise everyone
wow broncos are going to surprise
everyone shout out to you aiden you are
walking away with a hoodie um bagel and
locks bagel and lox he was in the
comments earlier hating but guess what
connor you know what we do to negative
vibes bad vibes we turn bad vibes into
good vibes so uh
you are walking away bagel unlocks you
are walking away with a hoodie but let
me give his take it's take set coats all
day they got matt ryan got a good coach
got a running game out there they might
can do something uh in indianapolis but
connor that that's it for this segment
that that's it that's enough hoodies to
give away and i gave away a jersey shout
out to everybody uh continue continue to
keep commenting because we got more and
more giveaways
to give away
all right and continue to stay on
draftkings for more conference odds in
the meantime we had a chance to catch up
with the director of the draftking
sportsbook johnny avello to talk 2022
futures look at this market take a look
at our conversation with johnny
all right now really excited to welcome
in a familiar face a legend of the
draftkings sports book johnny avello
johnny it's future season for the nfl
how are we doing right now good connor
doing great thank you we're ways from
the season starting but uh no reason not
to get excited it's that time of year
where we get a little bit too excited
and get ahead of ourselves so i got to
ask you
what are the most popular bets right now
coming in for mvp are there any
surprising names you've seen in the mix
so far
well when you look at the category
there's one position that dominates and
that's the first 16 possible selections
are all quarterbacks tom brady's at 10-1
he's getting the most money so far
followed closely by josh allen
they've been the two most popular
choices but
herbert 10-1 jackson 25-1 borough 12-1
they're all getting some attention now
you asked about a surprising name that
would be jalen hurts at 18 to 1 taking
about five percent of the money
and with the acquisition of aj brown
devante uh smith back for her sophomore
season i think the bettors are expecting
some bigger things there yeah the birds
fans usually show out too five percent
of the market that's a pretty good
number for jalen hurts considering 18 to
one so uh looking now that we're after
the draft here what is the most popular
offensive rookie of the year bet to date
right now
uh when i would be bruce hall uh nine to
one will step right into that jet
backfield and receive significant
playing time uh he's the top choice that
the other rookie that's seen quite a bit
of play in this market is christian
watson uh he's eight to one after
opening up 15 and one now
characters took him early in the second
round if he can catch the ball
half as well as devonta adams he might
be right in the mix for this award
that's a massive movement and uh that's
a name i was not expecting you to say so
with that being said speaking of massive
movements of lines what line has moved
the most as a result of all this
offseason wagering so far well kind of
we put up all those international games
for the entire season
and the one we've seen the most movement
on is the seahawks versus the bucks
on november 13 in the lions arena now
i'm not talking about raiders home
alliance stadium in las vegas now i'm
talking about the home of the european
football club the fire
unit team uh we opened tampa an eight
point favorite they are now up to nine
wow a full point movement and you and i
are having this conversation in may
football the football markets are truly
unbelievable and i am guilty as charged
all right what has been the most popular
new market this year uh are you rolling
out any new markets this upcoming season
we've seen draftkings roll out new stuff
every year it's been a lot of fun to
watch
we put up these markets called division
specials
and one division that's really popular
is the afc west you know that's due to
the division being just totally stacked
with russell wilson now bronco devonte
adams or raider and the chiefs and the
chargers both improving their teams
we're seeing this prop most regular
season passing yards between herbert
mahomes carr and wilson taking a bunch
of action
uh herbert's now to six to five favorite
a couple other props out there that
involve that same division or that are
really trendy are will all four teams
make the playoffs 20 to one
uh on the s
and pick the exact order of finish in
the afc west
and those odds range from seven and a
half to one to 35 to one
god so the bloodbath west is literally
creating their own markets at this point
just when you thought they couldn't be
stopped johnny avello it is always great
to talk to you my friend thanks so much
you're welcome connor
johnny avello and my man connor rogers
connor that's three different outfit
changes in one show i think we got to
put odds on it is it three and a half is
it gonna go over three and a half or
under three and a half you guys let me
know in the comments my man connor
rogers is changing fits like no other on
this show but uh
i'm in the comments that's why i'm here
i'm in the comments because i'm here to
give away some hoodies and 250 dk
dollars and i see
i see moneyline killer moneyline killer
says eagles and raiders over eight love
that take been seeing that on my feed uh
for the last several day a couple days
actually
so i like that shout out to you money
moneyline killer you are walking away
with the hoodie also giving out a jersey
here
and i'm looking for a good take and i
see r blount zero or blount zero
never any love for the coats plus 1200
is great value hey colts fans you guys
are getting some love i'm sending you
250 dk dollars r blunt zero
the coats may not be getting love from
the media but guess what greg is sending
you love i'm sending you 250 dk dollars
connor
let's get to the nitty gritty let's get
to the juicy part of the show let's talk
mvps brother
yeah it's time to get serious greg let's
talk mvp since the year 2000 only four
players have won the nfl mvp
that were not quarterbacks this is a
quarterback award anything else is a
long shot there are only quarterbacks on
this short list
of potential mvps the odds board is
dominated by the signal callers josh
allen and patrick mahomes the only ones
coming in at under plus a thousand and
then a wide open board of herbert brady
rogers
burrow russell wilson and matthew
stafford all right greg what do you like
here on this one
you see that man
four from the top his name is uh tom
brady plus 1 000
i think my guy is going to go out with a
bang connor last year i just i'll just
read some of his numbers uh 5
316 passing yards
43
touchdowns thrown my man had a passer
rating of 102.1
this was this is this man's 40 plus
connor he's 40 plus and he was actually
considering retiring after having a year
like that i think he's gonna come back
and do it even better
uh they might have a deep run into the
playoffs too they might have a deep run
into the playoffs but they might
meet up with a team from uh the west
coast and
might uh take tom brady's uh
championship aspirations away but i do
like tom brady to win mvp talk to me
talk to you connor i mean talk to the
people
which way are you leaning with this one
i like that pick greg i think brady's
got uh four games to stat pad in his own
division against the falcons and the
panthers as well and he can just get by
his kryptonite that is the saints he's
going to be
right at the top of that board by season
10. so i'm you took some value you
didn't take one of the top guys that
were under a thousand i'm doing the same
thing i'm going to take joe burrow here
i really like
our conversation earlier on the show how
joe burrow could spread the ball around
he's got you marc chase he's got t
higgins he's got tyler board tyler boyd
they spent a lot of money on this
offensive line and free agency and i
think it's gonna pay dividends and i
think it could pay dividends for those
betting on joe burrow at plus 1200 for
the mvp greg where are the comments
going right now it's a pretty wide open
board for this one
connor let me see what the comments is
talking about i'm in the comment the
comments right now
seeing what they're talking about okay
zach young says herbie herbie over 45
touchdowns this year okay i can see that
i can possibly see that i also see uh
adam spicer
plus 2000 on derek henry moore
run heavy now that brown is gone
derek henry in the tennessee titans
and connor
i'm giving away i think a jersey here
think i'm giving away a jersey here i
got joe burrow for mvp rm buckman 79 he
is rocking with your play connor so
shout out to you aaron buckman you are
walking away with a jersey
of your choice
all right visit draftkings for more
player awards futures including rookie
of the year both offensive and defensive
rookie of the year we asked you in the
app to drop your locks though for
receiving yards title you see cooper cup
there at the top plus 700 he was the
offensive player of the year last year
so no surprise to see him there justin
jefferson an absolute target monster
right behind him at plus 800 then this
board opens up greg you got kelsey there
you got jamar chase there uh you have
devonte adams of course tyree kill
stefan diggs tied at plus 1400 and then
devo samuel if he wasn't also a running
back in a sense he'd probably be even
higher on this board as well so
vr betting's own natalie bodie is going
to join us to go over some of our
favorite takes and we're going to give
away 250 dk dollars to our favorite
commenters not commenter commenter so
you want to stick around and get in on
the action here let's welcome natalie to
the show right now what's up natalie do
you have any favorite futures you're
looking at for this off season
here what's up guys you know connor i
live in atlanta so at some point i've
gotta root for the hometown team maybe
the falcons and over five wins it's it
plus money
unsure my confidence level there but
let's talk some receiving yards you guys
here are three of my favorite comments
from the people of course and the first
one is actually from tommy he's at icky
shuffle in our app who says that he
likes devonta adams with those odds at
plus 1200 of course is what he's
referring to what do you guys think of
adams at this spot
i love it this would be my pick on that
board as well if i wasn't looking to go
much much deeper i think the odds are
very fair at plus 1200 you're getting
some value i think he's walking into a
situation that uh he's going to be a
target monster the familiarity there
already with derek carr when they played
together at college together carr
obviously a huge proponent of this trade
hunter renfro's there darren waller's
there they're nice players but they're
not going to be the focal point of this
offense that devonte adams is and they
just traded another wide receiver while
we've been on the air and brian edwards
so that is even more targets on the
plate for davonte adams i love this pick
hey i'm right there behind you connor i
like this pic a lot as well you
mentioned devontae playing with his
former college teammate so the chemistry
is going to be there
but uh to lead the league i
i don't know if i'm gonna
love this play
i think i like somebody down down on the
list a little bit more my man from the
buffalo bill stefan dix but uh i do like
this one i do like this one a lot
natalie
plus 1200 is juicy i'm with you guys i
like that number especially with the
adams and car duo teaming back up we
can't forget they won the mountain west
championship at fresno state so i'm not
sleeping on that mountain west duo but
what do you guys think about this next
comment we've gotta potentially buy a
source let's be honest at cincy dude is
his name he says chase duh so jamar
chase at plus 1200 is that as obvious as
this guy thinks what you got connor
i think the duh is a little rich but i
respect it from the username cincy dude
repping his own team i love jamar chase
he's the best wide receiver i've ever
evaluated coming out of the nfl draft i
just think with the bengals it's
actually more of a compliment to their
team that they can spread the ball
around the easier than a lot of these
other guys on the board t higgins is
quietly maybe one of the best number
twos in the nfl right now they have
tyler boyd as a number three i think
they'll throw to joe mixon and burrows a
guy that when you go back all the way to
his breakout season at lsu in 2019 he
likes to keep everybody happy he likes
to keep all of his targets fed he will
spread the football around and the book
is out on jamar chase he's one of the
best wide receivers in the entire nfl
already and not even 23 years old right
now so teams are going to bracket him
he's going to see double teams teams are
gonna say somebody else beat us
that's okay for the bengals they'll be
able to do that to win games it's not
good for betting on jamarche's futures
i'm right there behind you connor i
don't think this one is a duh bet this
is one isn't a lot for me uh this is the
second year we know in the nfl usually
guys are less productive in the second
year than they were in the first year uh
adjustments will be made adjustments
will be made for jamar chase so i just
don't know if i can bet on him to lead
the league in receiving you mentioned it
connor we know what my man joe burrow
likes to do he throws the ball 50 times
a game almost he's spreading that rock
around uh so
i i just don't know if i'm willing to
bet jamar chase to have the most
receiving yards next year
looks like we're all in agreement there
i'm with you guys vero's got a lot of
targets i'd rather sprinkle my money
elsewhere let's go to this next comment
though our third comment from
at5018 he says if dak played a whole
game instead of the fourth quarter only
cd would have a shot he's of course
talking about cd lam at plus 1800 what
do we think
i like a dark horse pick i'll always uh
vote up for that i think though
the problem is kind of in play here
right what dak are we going to get it's
not just dag it's the entire dallas
offense a offensive line that's been
reworked a little bit they're going to
be playing some younger players there
no amari cooper which might open up more
targets for cd lamb i know they drafted
jalen tolbert but now c.d lamb is the
number one guy in that offense but it's
just a matter of how much attention is
he going to see from the defense as well
and how is he going to adjust to that cd
lamb has done a ton of damage from the
slot with cooper and gallop on the
outside now it's a little bit more on
his shoulder so
i like the value i'm not really the
biggest fan of the pick and i think 5.0
said it right here he's not even the
biggest fan of this pick because it's
hard to trust their first half offense
yeah yeah i love the value i don't know
if i'm picking this exactly uh
that i can see them having over 5 000
yards past we know they like to pass the
ball down there in dallas but my thing
is
is he gonna lock in on cd lam he has a
lot of weapons out there he has a lot of
weapons in dallas is he gonna lock in on
cd lam to have him have the most
receiving yards this year i just don't
know if i'm willing to bet that and like
you said conor even
5.018 don't even know if he's going to
bet that because he doesn't have the
faith in deck so uh
this one this one's actually pretty
challenging for me to see cd lamb
winning or having the most receiving
yards in the nfl this year
with cooper gone they definitely need
him to step up i'm always hesitant to
depend on the cowboys really for
anything you guys but i'm from texas so
i can say that we're gonna move on
though and decide who wins that 250
dollars in dk dollars
look i gotta give it to cincy dude
simply because his comment with the duh
in there in all caps i like confidence
and conviction so you sir are going home
with 250 dk dollars
i like it greg you are usually the man
giving away the dk dollars on this show
what is your response to that
yeah yeah because not only is natalie
giving away 250 dk dollars but i'm in
the comments right now i'm live in the
comments giving away 250 dk dollars and
i see
jplev
2210 says cup at plus 700 honestly is
great
value so shout out to you you are
walking away with 250 dk dollars i just
want to say this natalie i matched it
250 bk dollars i also can give away 250
bk dollars here on the drop zone
of course you can greg of course you can
now happy to be here with you guys greg
glad you could one-up me there at the
end but awesome stuff youtube
natalie thanks so much for uh jumping on
the drop zone with us today thanks again
all right now it's time to talk super
bowl and give away our grand prize and
if you just jumped in with us that is a
250
a month bankroll for the entire nfl
season you're going to be sitting pretty
if you walk away with this one so super
bowl 57 is scheduled for february 12th
in arizona which team will be there to
hoist the lombardi trophy let's take a
look at the odds board right now super
bowl favorite buffalo bills did not know
i would say that in my lifetime i like
good for the bills fans plus 650 there
big expectations the bucks plus 700 tom
brady's last ride a lot of people think
kansas city and green bay mahomes and
rogers and uh the rams the defending
super bowl champs all at plus a thousand
and the chargers getting in on the fun
greg's niners there as well plus 1600
and then the broncos now led by russell
wilson at plus 1600 as well so greg
first off i want to know what you like
on this board or maybe off this board
and how does somebody win the grand
prize of a 250 per month bankroll for
the entire football season
first i need everybody to get in the
comments i'm about to give away hoodies
jersey and
that 250
a month bankroll that connor is talking
about for the football season to one
lucky winner what i need you guys to do
is get in the comments and tell me your
lock to win
the super bowl
now this one connor this one this one's
tough for me this one's tough because we
got the 49ers i told i chose them to win
the nfc and then we got the bills i
chose them to win the afc
you know how i feel about my 49ers but
i'm going to be real here we trey lance
is such a question mark
that i can't i cannot go right now and
bet on those 49ers even though those
odds are very
very juicy
it's just a question mark and i just
cannot make that commitment at this very
moment maybe in uh august i might be
able to commit after seeing some
preseason games but right now i just
cannot commit so therefore conor by
defaults by default
i'm rocking with the buffalo bills man i
think that they can get it done we talk
i already talked about it
last year i talked about it on the drop
zone i talked about the the the
offensive presence that they have the
defense that they have they brought in
those reinforcements i already mentioned
them but i'll mention them again my man
von miller oj howard to play tight in as
a target with stefan dix also brought in
jameson crowder to fill in the slot they
have the running game singletary they
have what it takes connor it's just
about them putting it together
and can they do it this year
right now in may i think that they can i
think that they can do it so i'm rocking
with the buffalo bills connor which way
are you riding
for the championship
big expectations for the bills and
they've earned that great roster great
improvements in free agency in the draft
right there so i like that pick greg i'm
sticking with the afc as well i think an
afc team ends up winning the super bowl
this year as much as i like the bucks on
the nfc side looking at the chiefs here
i'm looking at the chiefs the chiefs
have somehow become a little bit of the
forgotten man there's a couple of things
number one i like a little bit of the
value here as well with the chiefs pick
you are getting some value by picking
them i think we're also starting to
forget just how great patrick mahomes is
you see the plus 1000 right there andy
reid not going to be coaching forever i
think there's a little bit more urgency
there uh urgency this year they've made
a volume of moves instead of just
landing one big ticket star so i like
the chiefs here on the super bowl ticket
where are the comments going right now
we get a lot of chalk pics here greg are
they getting real down the board and
creative
my man adam spicer adam spicer said we
are sleeping on the vikings sleeping on
those vikings shout out to you all right
just because we're sleeping on the
vikings shout out to you adam spicer you
are walking away with the jersey go get
a vikings jersey why not moving on
moving on
rb139 says as much as i hate to say it
the browns if watson plays imagine that
team
with a quarterback gave us fire emoji
shout out to you you're walking away
with a hoodie uh eric solis said the
bucks shout out to you zapdos zapdos
says the chargers plus 1500.
uh they're all over the place
comments is all over the place link 21
niners d gets it done over the bills in
the super bowl i mean i can see that
happening link uh so shout out to
everybody that i just mentioned you are
walking away with hoodies but connor
the comments are all over the place it's
early it is early comments all over the
place but i guess we'll just have to see
what happens
next year's football season
greg i think you still have a jersey to
give away or are we uh we moving on to
the grand prize here
i still got a jersey if connor says i
have a jersey to give away i'm going to
give away a jersey i'm back into the
comments i'm back into the comments
and i see
jp
lev2210 says chargers are a dark horse
love the take
they did do a lot in the offseason to
build that team up love their
quarterback justin herbert is a baller
he's a baller love the tech you are
walking away with a jersey of your
choice
all right you've given away the jersey
how are we picking the winner of the
grand prize vr betting bankroll here
greg
all right connor you all have been in
the comments dropping your super bowl
locks now we're gonna spin a will with
all 32 nfl teams whichever team it lands
on
i'm picking one random person who picked
that team to win the br betting bankroll
that's
250 dollars a month for the football
season
okay connor are you ready because i'm
feeling the itch to spin this wheel
brother
let's get to it let's spin the wheel
all right let's let's get to it three
two
one and the wheel starts spinning there
it is there it is let's see which team
it lands on connor will it be your jets
will it be my 49ers will it be
who i wonder who it will be and it's
looking like it's going to be
the browns wow
the browns connor the browns are the
winner uh how do you feel about that
how do you feel about the browns
connor talk to me how do you feel about
that
i mean trust the wheel i mean the browns
fans have been waiting for this for a
long time desean watson's in town
although
he might be dealing with the suspension
so their playoff hopes might be on how
jacoby brissette can keep them
uh treading water i
i don't know about this greg i
there's gonna be somebody in the
comments though i'm assuming from the
dog pound that's gonna be feeling really
really good about this and that grand
prize
yeah i mean let me uh
connor the wheel picked the browns i'm
dumbfounded at the will picked brown but
the wheel picked the brown so someone
who took the browns is walking away with
the br betting bankroll i'm going to get
in the comments
right now i'm giving away hoodies giving
away hoodies first and then i'm going to
uh
give
then i'm going to give away
that
250 dollars a month so here we go i see
the saints k hogan 2 says saints
uh
shout out to you your walk away what
hoodie
ny718 says the bills shout out to you
you are walking away with a hoodie uh
one more hoodie nino adam nino adam says
the bears wow
hey i like that though it's a lot of a
lot a lot of uh
a lot of plus money if you're picking
the bears but connor
rb139
rb139 mentioned the browns
so shout out to you
three
rb139
you are the winner of the br betting
bank roll
so man run it up this football season
please run it up
man that's gotta be feeling real real
good if you learned anything today let
it be that you don't have to wait for
football season to start to get in on
the action as you see giving away
bankroll giving away jerseys giving away
dk dollars get on draftkings and bet
your favorite futures and be sure to
take advantage of that jets odds boost
went from minus one wait connor wait
wait wait wait brother wait wait i'm
i'm so sorry i did not mean to cut you
off but before you already know before
we get out of here i gotta hook some
more people up with some hoodies so i'll
make it quick gm34 you're walking away
with a hoodie uh i got rb139 you just
won but why not you're if you don't have
a hoodie i'm giving you a hoodie i also
see link link 21 link 21 you were
walking away with 250 dk dollars and one
more one more connor i got
adam spicer i don't know if you got a
jersey but you are walking away with a
jersey of your choice conor apologies
brother but i had to do it i just i just
added it for the people
i'll never have a problem with it when
it's for the people alongside greg ivory
i'm connor rogers congrats to all our
winners don't worry vr betting is going
to dm you in the app and take care of
you and get you your prizes we will be
back in august to kick things off for
the 2022
nfl season see you then
[Music]
you